SPEAKER: All right.
In this video, we're going to show how the central limit
theorem is used in conjunction with t-statistics to obtain p-values.
And later we'll see how they're used to construct confidence intervals as well.
So we're going to use the mouse example where we constructed
a difference in mean already.
What we're going to do now is construct the t-statistics.
For that we need to estimate the standard error.
And we do that by taking the square root of the variance of the sample estimate
of the variance-- it's not variance.
It's far-- divided by n, where n is the sample size.
That's up here.
And the we add variance of the control.
And that gives us an error estimate.
And we can form a t-statistic by simply dividing the observed difference
by its estimated standard deviation.
OK?
There we go.
Now, what's really useful about central limit theorem
is that if we're willing to assume that, in fact, it
is a good approximation, that the normal approximation holds
for the null distribution, then we don't need
to have access to the population data.
So in a realistic situation, where we don't have access to that data,
we can actually compute a p-value.
So the t-statistic, central limit theorem,
is telling us the null distribution is approximated by a normal distribution
with mean 0 and variance 1.
So that means that we can compute p-values by simply computing that.
So the function PNORM, tells us what proportion of normally distributed
data, which means 0 and standard deviation 1,
are lower than whatever value you put here.
So the p-value would be given to us by that.
Now that's only bigger.
So if we want to test bigger in absolute value,
then we multiply that by 2 because we needed the 2 tails.
And we have ourselves an estimate of a p-value.
OK, so now you notice that we did not use the population data at all.
We simply used the sample data at hand.
So now the question that we can ask ourselves
is, how good of an approximation this is.
And here is where we can use the population data to test that.
So we can again act as if we have access to that data.
And we redo this.
Let's put n here now.
We redo this.
But now, we divide the nulls by the standard error estimate.
Let's put that here.
And that'll give us the actual null distribution of that t-statistic, which
we're assuming, using central limit theorem
that it is, in fact, normally distributed.
So we run that.
Wait, we have to do read in the data first.
And the we run the code.
And now we can see how good this distribution is.
We'll load the rafalib package to make some pictures.
So if we make a Q-Q plot against the normal for these nulls,
it should be right on the line.
It should have slope 1 and intercept 0.
So we can check that by,
we just should do a reline 0, 1.
That means make a line with intercept 0 and slope 1.
And it should go right through the data.
And it's pretty close, telling us that the central limit theorem here
is, in fact, giving us a pretty good approximation.
So the p-value we obtained is a good approximation of the actual p-value.
So now to see when the t-statistic switched around very quickly,
let's change n to 3 here.
So let's see what this looks like if I do a simulation now.
But I'm sampling three values instead of 12.
We're going to see what happens to the null.
We redo the Q-Q norm plots.
And we can see that now the data does not follow a normal-- oh, sorry.
That's not quite right.
We have to change this to 3 as well.
Let's redo it.
It's not quite that bad.
And now we make these pictures.
And we can see it's still not very good.
There's values that are much bigger than what are predicted by the normal.
So in the case of a sample size of 3, the normal approximation
is not good at all with this particular data set.
And it is in this case that we would instead
use the t-approximation if, as we explained earlier,
we believed the original data follows a normal distribution,
then in fact, the t-approximation should work.
OK, so there's your simulation showing why it
is that we need a bigger sample sizes.
And in the next video we'll show how we actually run the t-test in practice.